اهلا من جديد اقتحمت قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي مخيمه جنين الشمالات الضفه
الغربيه صباح اليوم وافاد شهد عيان على
قوات كبيره حصلت منزله عائله راتب البالي
في حي الهدف في المخيم واستهدفته بقدفه
وقال جيش الاحتلال ان قواتها اقتحمت
المخيم لاعتقالي مقاوم فلسطينيا مطلوبا
لديها واضافت ان قوته تعرضت لاطلاق نار
قبل ان تتمكن من اعتقاله ثم الانسحاب
وفي نابلس الشماليه ضفه هدمت قوه الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي منزلا بشكل جزئي في قريه دوما
وقال الشهود عيان الى قواتنا من الاحتلال
مصحوبه بجرافه عسكريه اقتحمت القريه فجر
اليوم وشرعت بهدم المنزل المكونين من
طابقين بحجه عدم الترخيص لانه يقع في
المنطقه المصنفه جيم واكد صاحب المنزل انه
لم يتلقى اي اخطار من قبل بيهدم المنزل
الذي يقتل فيه اكثر من 10 اشخاص وقال
مسؤول ملف الاستيطان شماليه الضفه غسانس
ان قوه الاحتلال هدمت حظيره اغنام ايضا
وغرفه زراعيه تعود للمواطنين اخرين في
القريه دون تحديد اسباب